you talked a lot about your family the
last time you were here so how are your
girls doing the girls are great they are
they're getting bigger and bigger our
new thing we're kind of worried about is
they
they're singing songs now they're
sharing content and which is fine but
one is nine and one is four and so I
have a four-year-old right now who's
running around the house singing Unholy
by Sam Smith
okay to listen to them but I have a
four-year-old walking around the house
like Daddy got caught cause he's popping
it and I'm like Daddy didn't pop
anything he didn't pop anything he
didn't go to a body shop he's not doing
Daddy made dinner Daddy was at home so
we need you are not abandoned I'm you're
not abandoned I'm here we need clean
lyrics We need the the Kidz Bop version
of it yeah like Daddy got caught at the
donut shop yeah bringing Donuts home
yeah because he loves us so much
here's the thing you can get it can get
awkward here we go okay what is the name
oh
what is the name of the simple sugar
that starts with an F that is a
sweetener in honey I don't know like a
sugar what's like a sugary thing that
usually is oh this is found in the
ingredient like
a fruit
doesn't count it doesn't count
is gone
it came back I need Redemption
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
I'm going
[Music]